ali leforce is on the floor with our
guest tonight marcus morris ali take it
away
marcus what was it like having patrick
beverly back
ah man we you know we missed him a lot
you know his intensity
you know that's like you know it's a
little bro right there man so i ain't
gotta do too much talking a lot i'm do
something
it's pretty remarkable when you think
about the fact that that was just your
13th
game as a team fully healthy did you
like how it looked
i think we played all right i think i
think it you know i think it works
when you think about the fact that this
is all happening so quickly right this
this franchise hasn't been to a
conference final do you guys have the
ability to do that what still needs to
happen with this team in your opinion to
get to that level
oh man we just come in every day and you
know we're working hard you know guys
are on the same page you know we have
high iq guys so
you know it's fun man uh you know with a
coach like doc is
you know he's putting it all together
you know and it's coming out with
outcome
i think there was a new good luck charm
maybe family in the stands had something
to do with the blog tonight
you know a little benjami out there for
me all my family came and
you know it feels good to be able to
have him here and uh you know i enjoyed
it
good luck the rest of the way thank you
thanks so much marcus yep
marcus morris from philadelphia he and
his twin
markief played college ball together
played high school basketball together
in
philly and came into the nba at the same
time and
they have uh contributed wherever
they've been but